itani I got a really great reception um
have you heard from Tonya Harding yeah
yeah yep yep now I just checked in with
a she actually messaged me on the way to
the premiere and we messaged for a
couple days after that just kind of
while the reviews came in yeah because
it's a super confronting thing I think
to have your life put up on the screen
have the world see it all over again
from a different point of view so yeah
no but she was great about it do you
think that you would take her with you
to the Academy Awards that would she go
yeah yeah I mean I wanted to kind of be
as involved as she wants to be but for
now Margo is focused on co-starring with
Kelly Macdonald and goodbye Christopher
Robin which shows how the story of
Winnie the Pooh was created to be happy
but I think I've got something for us so
who would you say that you guys are in
the like the cast I think the Winnie the
Pooh cares I go for kanga how about we
celebrate with silence no I'm Australian
I should get King Margot plays mom will
Kelly plays nanny to young Christopher
Robin who inspired his dad to write the
classic tale go bless mommy go best
daddy
god bless you you guys both play two
sort of different sizes at this maternal
role for Christopher in the movie what
was it like working with young
he was a joy it's just such a good
little Harrison he's an old soul and he
knew all these lanes he knew exactly
what he was supposed to do he was just
completely professional and Jessica he
was name was he no but he was just
exactly and it wasn't like a stage kid
in any way was just like really
interested and everything and and just
like it just could company earnest
tonight putting your bear in a book or
putting you in it too
what do you call me in the book your
real name Christopher Robin did you guys
grow up reading Winnie the Pooh or
watching the movies like did you have a
lot of Winnie the Pooh in your life
growing up I had a Winnie the Pooh toy
that my mom used to play with but I
didn't actually I don't know she ever
read the books to me or if it was just
the character we needed who that was
kind of sprinkled throughout my
childhood yeah I I didn't read the books
growing up but it was more than the
films the Disney film as I was aware of
yeah I think we're a couple generations
removed from like the madness of like
the whole Christopher Robin celebrity
thing that is shown in the movie was
that surprising to you that at that time
and at that age like how young he was he
was that popular yeah and I think I've
just taken for granted that we need to
pull existed throughout my whole life so
I never really questioned its origins
and to kind of find out that what made
it so important to people was the time
that it came out and that was that was a
big discovery and then kind of looking
into what was happening at the time and
the fact that it was right between World
War one and World War two and and what
it kind of did for this country in the
world at a time
this was really really fascinating to me
[Music]